I have covered the local AI package a
lot on my channel it is hands down the
easiest way to get all your local AI up
and running in a single stack for free
I'm talking your llms databases
automation tools Local web search and
your user interface and as I'll show you
you can use this package to super easily
spin up local AI environments in the
cloud on demand because here's the deal
even with local AI you don't always want
it running on your own computer because
maybe you have other people like your
internal team that you want to be using
your local AI setup or you want it
running 24/7 and you don't want your
stack constantly hogging all the
resources on your machine or maybe you
just want access to Hardware that you
don't have and really it could be all of
these reasons combined together and the
good news is that deploying your local
AI stack to the cloud solves for all of
this and it is still considered local as
long as you manage the cloud instance
and and so in this video I will walk you
through step by step taking the local AI
package and deploying it to your very
own private Cloud instance so you can
have the local AI dream without being
stuck to only your machine plus with
some new additions to the local AI
package this process could not be easier
so this is very much a straightforward
no fluff guide and I'll even cover Cloud
providers and different Hardware
requirements cuz I know those are big
considerations for local AI as well and
on top of all this I'll show you how to
set up subdomains for things like n8n
and open web UI so it is very much an
endtoend guide now this is the local AI
package I'll have a link to this GitHub
repo in the description of this video
the beauty of this package is we take
all of these local AI services that you
see right here bundle it all together in
a way where we can install it and
configure it in just a few steps that I
have outlined in this readme it is so
simple to get everything up and running
and in a previous video on my channel
that I'll link to right here I show how
to use these steps to get everything set
up on our own computer and now we're
going to do it in the cloud so this
package which was originally created by
the n8n team I've extended to include
all of these services so we've got n8n
superbase olama open web UI flow wise
quadrant and then recently I added CRX
NG for local and private web search
which includes reddis for caching by the
way and then what's really important for
this video is I included caddy now which
is managed https and TLS so this is how
we can have secure endpoints for all of
our services that we have running in the
clouds you can go to N.Y yourdomain.com
for example and that'll bring you right
to the n8n instance hosted securely in
the cloud and that is with caddy so
that's really important for this here
and so I'll walk through all these steps
now and I'll show you how to go through
this in a way that will work for really
any Linux machine that you have in the
cloud so it doesn't matter if you're
using digital Ocean or Lambda Labs AWS
your own server if you have your own
data center you can follow these steps
I'm making it as generic as possible so
it can apply to you no matter really
where you're deploying your local AI
setup so for this video we're going to
be using digital ocean to deploy our
local AI package they are not sponsoring
this video this video doesn't have a
sponsor at all I just use them myself I
generally recommend them that's why I'm
covering them here and they have the
best options in my mind for CPU
instances so if you're not running
larger local llms that require a
dedicated GPU digital ocean gives you
the best options that I've seen you also
have aami Cloud previously known as
linode it's another good option for CPU
instances too and then a quick barrage
here for GPU instance platforms the main
point I want to get across is to do your
own research based on your needs and
budget there are a lot of options out
there because we've got Lambda Labs
vulture we have paper space which is a
part of digital ocean but is its own
platform and then if you want to go more
Enterprise of course we've got AWS
Google cloud and Microsoft Azure all of
these are going to provide you with GPU
instances that you can deploy the local
AI package to in the exact same way that
we are going to do with digital ocean
there are only a few platforms that
don't work the best and I'll just cover
those really quickly I want to make sure
that I cover this all so that you guys
aren't left using a platform that just
doesn't work because tensor do is one of
them it's a great platform for cheap
gpus but they don't allow you to open up
all the ports that you need for the
local AI package and then we have
platforms like runp pod and novita which
are also great but they deploy
everything as containers and since you
can't run containers within containers
very easily it's a lot more work to get
the local AI package spun up in one of
these and so that's why I'm sticking
with digital ocean as well they do also
offer GPU droplets if you want to pay
more to have something really beefy for
your local llms so now let's move on to
creating our instance so I have a brand
new project set up in digital ocean I'm
going to go ahead and click on Create
and then droplets in the top right to
keep costs low for this demo I'm going
to be creating a CPU instance so there's
no dedicated GPU so I'm going to choose
my region go down and then select this
instance for $42 a month it gives us 8
GB of RAM and two CPUs this is enough
for the entire local AI package unless
you want to run larger local llms so if
you want to run any llms that are larger
than seven or eight billion parameters
you will need a dedicated GPU and that
will cost you a pretty penny more but
that's required if you want to use
larger llms like 14 32 or 70 billion
parameters but a lot of people will opt
to do a CPU instance because it's
cheaper and they'll just host AMA
somewhere else or just use an API like
open router because at least the rest of
their stack is still private and local
they're not paying anything for those
Services except for the machine to host
it so that's what we're going to be
doing right here and of course if you
have your own server hopefully you've
got a GPU so you have that covered and
then for our image I want everything set
up with Docker already and Ubuntu is the
most popular distribution of Linux so
I'm going to select this one right here
in the marketplace and so if you're
following along with any other provider
you will be able to find a new BTU Linux
instance you can follow along with all
the same commands that I'm going to be
covering and then for the authentication
SSH keys are a bit more secure but just
to keep it really simple here I'm going
to set up a password so I'm going to set
up my password and then for my host name
I'm just going to say YouTube local AI
package and then I'm going to do this
off camera click create droplet once I
have my password set and it come back
once my instance is ready all right so
now my instance is created I can click
into it now go to access and then launch
a droplet console with root because I do
need to have privileged access to run
some of these commands that I'll show
you here so I'm doing it as a root once
we are in our instance now the there are
a couple of steps that we need to do
before we can follow those Base
instructions and pull in the local AI
package repository so going back to the
read me here I have a dedicated section
for some of the extra things you have to
do when you are deploying to the cloud
because we have to open up some
firewalls and then also set up our DNS
records and so I'll walk you through
that right now first of all for the
firewall stuff I've already run these
commands in the instance you don't have
to watch me paste in all these commands
but you need to enable your firewall
rules and then open up the ports for all
of our different local AI services like
superbase flow wise and open web UI and
then n8n as well and then if you want to
expose CR xng or olama you can run these
commands as well the reason I don't do
these by default is because CRX andg and
AMA are not password protected like our
other services so You' just be exposing
it for anyone to use so typically I just
keep these private and I don't open up
these ports so the other local AI
services on the instance can access
cuz it's all through Local Host but then
outside and accessing from the internet
you wouldn't be able to use CR xng or
AMA so after you have all your firewall
rules set up you just run ufw reload and
then all of those rules take effect and
just keep in mind for all of these you
do have to have privileged access so
that's it for the firewalls now we need
to set up our DNS records and this is
going to be the same pretty much for no
matter your DNS provider so I'm using
hostinger it's not sponsored it's just
because this is what I use use for my
DNS for automator doai and what you want
to do is go to digital ocean find your
ipv4 and copy that and then you'll go
ahead and paste that in the points to
whatever that destination IP address is
and then we want it to be a type a
record and then for the name here this
is the subdomain that we want to use so
if we want
yt- nn. automator doai to point to the
n8n instance in our digital ocean
droplet we set it up like like this we
just say the name is yt- NN that is our
subdomain so I'll go ahead and add this
record click confirm and then we can do
this for all of our other ones as well
so I can do YT superbase I can add this
and then we can do open web UI and then
I'll add that and then lastly for now we
can do flow wise and you can do the same
thing for CRX olama any other services
that you might add yourself to the local
AI package as well so that is everything
for DNS and that's everything that we
have for our extra steps for deploying
to the cloud so now we can go up to the
top and we can run everything that we
have as the base installation steps so
I'm going to start by copying the get
clone command I'll go ahead and open my
instance back up paste this in Clone the
repo and then change my directory into
it so now everything we see with an LS
is what we have at the root of our
GitHub repo and one extra step that I
have to do here just because I have
everything in a feature Branch right now
I have to change my Branch you won't
have to do this though cuz I'll have
everything in the main branch by the
time you're watching this video but now
we have all the configuration for things
like caddy which I won't go over to this
in detail right here I want to keep this
tutorial concise and the things that you
care about but you can dive into that if
you are curious but now what we want to
do is set up our environment variables
so I have an example for everything in
this env. example file so what we want
to do is copy the. example file and I'll
zoom in a little bit just to make it
really easy for you to see we want to
copy this into a newv file and so now
the contents of VN EnV look exactly the
same as. env. example and so now we'll
use Nano to edit it and so this does
assume that you have Nano and git and
Docker already installed I do call that
out in the remme those are prerequisites
you can just install those based on your
Linux distribution if you don't have
them already let's go ahead and edit
this file so in the EnV file I have
comments that tell you which are
required and how to set up all of these
variables and so for n8n this is just
any alpha numeric string that you want
to set as something decently long to
make it secure and then for the
superbase secrets you want to set up
your postgress password and also the
login details for your superbase
dashboard and then I have links here
that bring you to the superbase
self-host guide this will help you set
up your JWT secret Anonymous key and
service roll key and it makes it very
very easy to go through that and then
for your pool or tenant ID you can set
this to just kind of whatever number you
want like 1,000 for example so really
easy to set up all these values the one
thing that I go through with you right
here is setting up the caddy
configuration because these are all of
our subdomains so let me show you this
I'm going to uncommon all of the
subdomains that we set up in hostinger
or whatever your DNS provider is and I'm
not going to uncomment AMA and cxg cuz
I'm not using those and then for the
let's encrypt R email you can just set
this to whatever your email is like I'll
do col medine automator doai and then
for the host names here obviously change
this to whatever subdomain you set up in
your provider and what your actual
domain is so for n8n for example it was
yt- nn. automator doai and then I'll
pause and come back once I have the
other ones set up all right there we go
all of our subdomains are exactly what
we have set up in our cloud provider so
now to save and exit from this file with
Nano there are a few commands first you
want to do contrl X then it'll ask you
if you want to save so you'll just type
Y and then finally you can press enter
so again that is contrl X then y then
enter and now the contents of this I'm
not going to print it out here because I
edited all my other Secrets as well
behind the scenes it'll print out that
entire EnV so you can make sure that
everything was applied and now we are
ready to run that script that's going to
spin up everything with lock ER and so
going back to the read me there are a
few different options for this command
because there are different profiles to
use depending on your GPU or if you want
to run in CPU mode so if you have a
cloud instance with an Nvidia GPU like
if you're using Lambda Labs or AWS or
something like that or a digital ocean
GPU instance then you'll run this
command maybe just replacing python with
Python 3 a lot of Linux distributions
you have to specify Python 3 for the
command we'll see see that in a second
for our case specifically since we just
have a CPU instance I'm going to run
this command to run the AMA instance on
my CPU because I don't have a GPU so I'm
going to copy that come back over here
and paste this in you'll see that it
says python not found so typically it
just means you have to add a three at
the end so specifying Python 3 I'll go
ahead and run this and now it's going to
kick off that entire process where it
pulls the super base repository and it
starts the super based containers
there's some settings behind the scenes
that it sets up for CRX and as well so
this script takes care of a lot of
things so you'll see it pull and run the
superbase containers and then it'll wait
a little bit and then it'll pull and run
the rest of the containers for our local
AI stack and it has it all together in a
single Docker composed Network so all of
the containers can communicate with each
other and this will take a little bit
because some of these containers are
rather large and it has to pull the AMA
model and import the n workflows and
everything and so I'm going to pause and
come back once this is done and just a
few minutes later we have all of our
containers up and running your logs
should look something like this and
there was a bit of a glitch with my
digital ocean droplet here that's why
you see some blank space but your logs
will look something like this where we
have the superbase containers pulled and
executed and then the same thing for the
rest of our local AI package for
everything like n8n open web UI and
caddy and to see all of your containers
running you can do the docker PS command
it'll show you every single one of the
containers in the stack you can make
sure that they all say that they are up
if you see any that are down or
restarting then you probably have some
sort of issue that you would want to
look into and you can also do Docker
logs DF and then the name of your
container and this will give you all the
logs for that specific container like
we're looking at caddy right here and
the- f means that it'll follow as more
logs come in as well so just a couple of
commands to help you manage your stack
but now we can go over to our browser
and test this out so I'll do a new tab
and I'll do yt- nn. automator doai and
there we go all right we have our Blank
Slate sign up page for n8n we could do
yt- superb. automator doai and it'll
take us to our dashboard asking us to
sign in we can do YT open web UI all
right there we go we got open web UI so
everything is working perfectly I'm able
to connect to it from an external
browser just on my computer and this is
beautiful and I'm not going to cover how
to use all these different platforms
here there are other videos on my
channel that I'll link to in the
description of this video if you want to
dive into how to create local agents
with n8n and ol and everything right
here we just wanted to focus on setting
up our local AI stack hosted in the
cloud and we have accomplished that so
there you have it the fastest way to
deploy your local AI setup to the cloud
and as a whole I have a lot more coming
for the local AI package as well because
I am always adding new new Services
making constant improvements and putting
out more content for things like guides
on creating local AI agents leveraging
this package so if you appreciated this
content and you're looking forward to
more things local Ai and AI agents I
would really appreciate a like and a
subscribe and with that I will see you
in the next video